انا وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه حسين امير
عبد الاهيان ان الحوار الذي جرى بينه وبين
وزير الخارجيه السعودي خلال مؤتمر بغداد
الثاني في الاردن اظهر ان ثمه اتفاقا في
وجهات النظر على ضروره استمرار الحوار بين
ايران والسعوديه بما يؤدي الى تطويع
العلاقات بين البلدين جاء هذا في مؤتمر
الصحفيين عقده في العاصمه اللبنانيه بيروت
مع نظيره اللبناني
الذي عقد في الاردن كانت هناك فرصه لتبادل
لحوار قصير بيني وبين وزير الخارجيه
السعودي وكان هناك اتفاق في وجهات النظر
بشان استمرار الحوار السعودي الايراني بما
يؤدي في نهايه المطاف الى تطبيع العلاقات
بين البلدين نرحب بعوده العلاقات الطبيعيه
بين ايران والسعوديه وصولا الى افتتاح
السفارتين في الرياض وطهران في اطار
الحوار الذي ينبغي ان يستمر بين البلدين
مرحبا وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير
عبد الحيان بالحوار الذي يجري بين مسؤولين
اجراك وسوريين واعتبر ان الحوار السوريه
التركيه بامكانه اي ينعكس بشكل ايجابيا
على مصلحه البلديه
بين سوريا والتركيا ولقاءات التي تعقد بين
مسؤول البلدين نعتقد ان هذا الحوار
بامكانه ان ينعكس بشكل ايجابي على مصلحه
البلدين وهو الطريقه الانجع والافضل
لايجاد مخرج لمساله العلاقه السوريه
بامكاننا ان نتابع هذا الموضوع من خلال
الالتزام بمفاوضات استنى مع اعطاء الدوري
للحضور السوري في هذا الحوار
والتانيث مع مراسل الجزيره ايهاب العقدي
ايهاب مرحبا بك اضافه الى ما جاء في
المقطعين السابقين ماذا في اجنده عبد الله
هيان في بيروت
طبعا زياره تاتي في اطار الاهتمام التي
تبديه ايران بالوضع اللبناني
لقاءات مختلفه سيجريها عبد الالهيان في
بيروت بالاضافه الى وزير الخارجيه هناك
اجتماع مع رئيس الحكومه رئيس حكومه تصريف
الاعمال نجيب ميقاتي ومع رئيس البرلمان
النبي بري وايضا في جدول زيارته لقاءات مع
المسؤولين في حزب الله وايضا مع قيادات
الفصائل الفلسطينيه في لبنان همم الوزير
الايراني تحدث باهتمام عن مساله
دعوه او حتى ايران لانتخاب رئيس جديد
لبنان خلال هذه المرحله وتحدث ايضا عن
استعداد ايران وهو تكرار لمواقف سابقه بان
ايران ترغب همم تصدير الوقود الى لبنان
الذي يحتاجه في هذه المرحله خصوصا وان
معامل الطاقه في لبنان اصبحت همم تكاد لا
تعمل بسبب بش الوقود وعدم قدره لبنان على
دفع المبالغ المتواجبه لتوليد الطاقه
اللازمه للبنان كما ابدا ايضا استعداد
بلاده لانشاء معامل التوليد جديده اذا
استوجب الامر وزير الخارجيه اللبناني عبد
الله ابو حبيب وفي المؤتمر الصحفي المشترك
قال ان مساله توريد الوقود الايراني الى
لبنان امامه معه معوقه معوقه داخليه ترتبط
بمواقف سياسيه للاطراف اللبنانيه المختلفه
وهؤلاء وهناك ايضا عائق اقليمي يرتبط
بالعقبات المفروضه على ايران سبق ولرئيس
الحكومه اللبنانيه قد ان اعلن بانه سيخاطب
او سيتواصل مع الاداره الامريكيه ربما
للوصول الى اتفاق بشان استثناء لبنان من
اي عقوبات على تصدير الوقود الايراني اليه
هذا الامر هو ربما الاساس في الزياره
وفيما اعلن حتى اللحظه في اطار لقاءات
الله ايضا التي سيجريها عبد الالهيان ربما
يصدر مواقف اخرى ترتبط بالوضع اللبناني
وننتظر لي ما سيديه خلال ربما السعاده
واليوم المقبل ايضا الذي لديه فيه لقاءات
مع المسؤولين في حزب الله والفصائل
الفلسطينيه شكرا جزيلا لك ايهاب العقد من
بيروت